dibujar bien las reacciones ha sido base
es una habilidad muy importante cuando
estás haciendo mecanismos de reacción en
química orgánica así es que vamos a
observar una reacción ácido base aquí en
la izquierda tenemos ácido acético que
en esta reacción va a funcionar como
nuestro ácido de braunstein lori y va a
donar un protón y aquí en la derecha
tenemos hidróxido de sodio que va a
funcionar como nuestra base de brawn
usted lo lee y va a aceptar a un protón
ahora cuando dibujamos el mecanismo
utilizamos las flechas curvas para
denotar el movimiento de electrones y
aquí en el hidróxido estos dos
electrones son los que van a tomar el
protón ácido de este ácido acético así
es que ya dibuje aquí mi flecha curva y
estos dos electrones solo se van a
llevar al protón y entonces estos dos
electrones que forman este enlace se
quedan aquí en el oxígeno
vamos a dibujar el producto tenemos por
aquí estos carbonos doble enlace con el
oxígeno que tienen sus dos pares de
electrones y por aquí tenemos este
oxígeno que tenía ya dos pares de
electrones pero se va a quedar con estos
dos electrones entonces tiene otro par
de electrones y tiene ahora una carga
formal negativa -1 también tendríamos
por aquí un catión de sodio y podemos
pensar en esto se está formando aquí un
enlace iónico y luego que es lo que
obtenemos sea o h - le agregamos un
protón lográis se agregamos h más o
menos pues lo que obtenemos es h2o o
agua porque y entonces tenemos por aquí
una molécula de agua y el oxígeno tiene
sus dos pares de electrones ahora vamos
a ver paso por paso donde quedaron los
electrones ok este par de electrones del
anillo
hidróxido fueron y se quedaron con este
protón entonces por acá vamos a decir
que esos dos electrones son este enlace
de aquí y que este protón es este protón
de acá podría ser el otro pero da lo
mismo y luego tenemos estos electrones
de aquí que se quedan en el oxígeno y
están por acá y le dan a este oxígeno
una carga formal negativa entonces esto
de aquí fue una reacción ha sido base y
de hecho aquí podemos identificar los
pares ácido base conjugados y en la
izquierda tenemos el ácido acético que
es nuestro ácido de browns de dolor y
qué y cuál es la base conjugada del
ácido acético pues lo tenemos por aquí
ese lannion aceptado esta es la base
conjugada del ácido acético
base
con jugada y para el hidróxido que
funciona como nuestra base de brawn
usted lo es
cuál es su ácido conjugado pues lo
tenemos aquí a la derecha si alan jon
hidróxido le agregamos un protón lo que
obtenemos es una molécula de agua
entonces el agua es el ácido conjugado
del hidróxido
ha sido conjugado
jugador
aunque entonces ya identificamos los
pares conjugados ácido base y ahora
vamos a ver el error más común que
cometen las personas en reacciones ácido
base y ese error es en las líneas curvas
aunque ahí lo voy a dibujar en rojo para
que recuerdes que no debes de cometer
este error el error más común que he
visto es tomar este protón y tomar una
flecha curva que lleve a este protón
hacia acá y eso está completamente mal
porque la flecha curva lo que denota es
el flujo de electrones no el movimiento
de protones
este protón si se va con este oxígeno
pero con esta flecha estamos diciendo
que es un electrón el que se va hacia el
oxígeno aunque hay estos dos electrones
son los que van y se llevan al protón
entonces esto es incorrecto no dibujes
tus reacciones ha sido base de esta
forma y
ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo para
tener más práctica por aquí tenemos
aceptó na y en la derecha tenemos ión
hebrón ya que es h 3 o más el hidro nio
va a funcionar como nuestro ácido de
browns de dolor y ha sido de brawn usted
nori y le va a donar un protón a nuestra
aceptó na la cual va a funcionar como
nuestra base de brawn usted loring y
recuerda muy bien que cuando dibujemos
flechas curvas lo que estamos mostrando
es el movimiento de electrones entonces
si la acetona está funcionando como una
base uno de estos pares de electrones se
va a llevar uno de estos protones y
dejar estos electrones con el oxígeno
entonces ahora vamos a dibujar el
resultado tenemos por aquí el oxígeno
con su doble enlace con un carbono y los
otros dos carbonos aunque el oxígeno
tiene un par de electrones libres por
acá
y con el otro par de electrones libres
está formando un nuevo enlace con el
protón que se acaba de llevar y ahora
tiene una carga formal positiva y de
este lado acabamos de formar una
molécula de agua aunque tenemos el
oxígeno con sus dos hidrógenos
y dos pares libres de electrones y ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es seguir a todos
estos electrones estos dos electrones de
aquí fueron y formaron un enlace con
este protón así es que estos dos
electrones están aquí formando este
enlace y estos electrones de azul que
estaban formando este enlace se quedaron
en el oxígeno formando un par de
electrones libres y transformando a esta
molécula en una molécula de agua
entonces nada más nos falta identificar
a los pares conjugados así dos bases
aquí tenemos una molécula de hebrón ya
que es nuestro ácido de browns de lori y
si tomamos ese ácido y le quitamos un
protón lo que nos queda es la base con
jugada base
con jugada si el libro no le quitamos un
protón lo que nos queda es una molécula
de agua que es la base conjugada y por
aquí la acetona está funcionando como
nuestra base de browns de dolor y
entonces esto que nos queda por acá
tiene que ser el ácido conjugado ácido
conjugado con jugador aunque ya
identificamos los pares conjugados
ácidos base y mostramos el movimiento de
electrones con estas flechas curvas y
así es que ya terminamos pero tienes que
practicar tus mecanismos de reacción
ácidos base porque en verdad son
extremadamente importantes y tienes que
poder escribirlos rápidamente cuando
estás haciendo un mecanismo de reacción
de química orgánica